foreign
what was it like then to sit down
and write a memoir whether at the
beginning or in the middle
it was really challenging in the sense
that the resistance that you feel I
think to writing a memoir the voice in
your head says who's going to give a
about your stupid stories you know
everybody in the world's got a million
of these things wise yours can be any
different so that's that was a big part
of it the flip side of that was before I
die
I want to put some of this down it
shouldn't just go away you know even if
it's only you know my family you know my
nephews and nieces that they should be
able to read this but then above and
beyond that and this is I know sort of
where we've been trending into the this
conversation about the hardcore physical
reality of the stuff was like how do I
tell this story you know what do
I leave out yeah what do I leave in
what's the point of view what's my tone
of voice who is I in this story if I'm
telling it in the first person so that
was sort of a big Challenge and again I
sort of did what we were talking about
before or what I was talking about about
Blitzkrieg of
it would have overwhelmed me if I didn't
just do it yeah so
so I just did it
and when it was done I'd left out a lot
of chunks and a lot of this I thought
I wish I had a real editor which I
didn't at this point and I just sort of
had to make the decision of I'm going to
edit it myself this is it this is what
it's going to be
for good or ill yes I don't know if
that's yeah I'm kind of Meandering a
little bit Tim no that's okay so
government cheese
what's the title about uh one of the
articles that we delivered in this
trucking company was surplus food
to poor communities on the coast in
North Carolina and uh this was because I
was the most Junior driver this company
this was like the lowest paying job in
the and the load that people wanted the
least right so I got it all I mean I
made like to make these runs was like I
would make fifteen dollars
but I really love these runs and uh he
would drive all night and arrive really
early Before Dawn was always to a church
we were always distributed at a church
and it was always a black church with a
black congregation and a lot of the the
recipients were sharecroppers and stuff
like that but they also were sometimes
he'd have guys come in with hot Mustangs
you know with a great looking young
girls that kind of stuff but and what
you were delivering
the government cheese and the you know
the dried powdered milk and pinto beans
and stuff like that
was stuff that was going on people's
tables it was going to keep them alive
you know so you really felt like you
were doing some some good and
so what I sort of later
you know I just I just really enjoyed
these things I can't tell you how much
fun they were and and uh well the other
aspect is you were Anonymous in these
things when you would pull into the lot
I never had anybody you would talk to
the minister the minister would tell you
pull your vehicle over here and they
would always address you as a driver say
driver would you mind pulling this over
here never ask your name I don't know
why and and your role was sort of really
to recede into the background you didn't
participate you opened the doors and and
they took the food off the way they
wanted to so when all was said and done
this kind of goes back to the story I
was telling about Hugh Reeves
I feel like writing
is about delivering a load
it's sustenance you hope it's sustenance
right it's a load of
surplus food of government cheese that's
going to go on people's tables and there
are other aspect about that is you are a
vehicle for it I didn't grow the cheese
you know all I did was deliver it and
when I'm done the trailer's empty I
close it up and I go away and you know
do it again somewhere else
it's a metaphor for writing for me in
other words that that's what it was that
is
that's what government cheese means what
else would you like people to know
about this Memoir is there anything else
that you would like to to say about it I
mean your stories are incredible your
writing is incredible the cover quotes
you have are spectacular from a lot of
people I respect
what else would you like to say about
government cheese if anything well the
uh yeah there is one other thing I would
like to say that uh
like I say it's it's a writer's Odyssey
it goes from somebody that at the start
can't do it and at the end of it can do
it yeah and
one of the big takeaways from from my
story at least is that
there are a series of breakthroughs
along the way an emotional or but almost
always they never pay off in the moment
it's like you have a breakthrough and
nothing happens you know it's like 10
years later finally it pays off right so
that if anybody is listening to us today
Tim and thinking
you know trying to get any sustenance
out of that
one of the big lessons is it takes a
long time you know it's a real process
like you're working on your Eight houses
thing
it may be a few years yeah before you
really get a handle on this thing you
know for sure it would be amazing if you
came right out of the Chute and it
worked you know and yeah so that it
seems to me that the way these
breakthroughs work is they they need to
mature I mean they take time you know
you think oh I finished a book and then
for me I couldn't sell that book yeah
and I couldn't sell the next book you
know and it was like years and years
before I could so but but there is a
process and there is you know there is
significance and change is happening